[Musique]
sartre données personnelles et cookies
la présente charte est destiné aux
utilisateurs du site web et mobiles
doctissimo.fr et des applications
mobiles et tablettes
liv élise on épargne et 5800 mots à nos
téléspectateurs là quand même nom et
vous avez entendu peut-être le président
hier il a dit il faut nous habituer à
vivre le temps présent c'est assez
philosophe mais je trouve ça assez
angoissant pour être tout à fait honnête
le coït 19 a bouleversé le monde
il a également fait la fortune de ceux
qui ont contribué à fabriquer des
vaccins en tête de cette poignée de
nouveaux milliardaires en français
stéphane bancel 47 ans pdg de moderne ce
top 9 des milliardaires en dollars est
complété par trois co fondateur du
laboratoire chinois cansino biologique
ce à l'origine d'un vaccin unidose l'
ong oxfam a fait le calcul
leur fortune cumulée permettrait de
vacciner l'ensemble des pays pauvres et
en raison du coc vite ces événements
sont soit annulés soit on ne peut pas y
assister il était de créer quelque chose
qu'on pouvait porter en toutes occasions
et ce même pendant la grande guerre de
l'eau juste un petit beurre beau des
abonnés
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
star de la gère glaïeuls glaïeuls plus
que content plein
on a attendu trop longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pour certains un peu de stratégie
permet de contourner les règles il ya
déjà six personnes à la table je me dis
coops tu regardes d'une des filles que
j'aime pas trop je dis regarde la bahia
un chat qui courent je prend sa place
idéalement le barman très sympa nous dit
si vous cachez vous n'êtes pas très
grosse vous pouvez tenir un but c'est
bien de partager ces moments là non je
ne trouvais pas ça le truc qui te
prendre une force qui bossent ils
pensent liquide pour mettre au ban en
bas nous c'est notre boulot c'est la
fête parce que c'était on aurait cru que
c'était la fin de la guerre non je
trouve ça complètement ceux qui ne
respectent pas la règle sont contrôler
strictement mais pour certains clients
c'est parfois moins clair le couvre-feu
il est passé mais c'est important pour
toi de voeux non en fait vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec tous ces gens qui
effectivement hier se pavaner en
terrasse et c'est comme ça que vous le
vivez en fait philippe bagdad le mans
puis comme ceux qui sont allés aussi au
cinéma si j'aurais bien matin christophe
vouloir dit on aller au boulot à 6
heures
[Applaudissements]
merci jean messia qu'israël compte alors
vous avez prêté ce blouson beige du
syndrome on verra ça tout à leur merci
nous prenons un abonnement à cold crm
pour 129 euros par mois nous avons accès
à tous les numéros de la base
[Musique]
on y trouve par exemple les portables et
les mails personnels de gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur
regardez un cadre magique comme ça la
regarde et je n'ai pas aux éléves au
souk al araji
jean marie bigard rossy a été la
présence j'ai failli l'oublier
lui aussi a eu droit à son cette fille
avec eric zemmour il explique ainsi sa
présence sur twitter je suis pour la
police je les remercie d'exister et
maintenant l'ex premier flic de france
et son message d'accueil très personnel
oui bonjour jai journalistes qui se sont
introduits au mans on est rentré tout à
fait normalement madame on est émouvant
on est en fait tout à fait normalement
avec la cie messieurs ce vidéaste
voulait simplement présenter sa petite
amie à sa communauté mais marcus est
très proche trop enthousiaste et elle
semble mal à l'aise
cela n'a pas échappé à un internaute qui
a imaginé un britannique pris en otage
depuis ce petit ajout vidéo les
utilisateurs de tik tok rivalisent
d'imagination pour parodier cette scène
allant jusqu'aux policiers à l'extérieur
de l'appartement et a fait souci
monsieur avec à 6 ce sont des sujets
d'intérêt général pour les gens qui nous
sur votre site ou sur vos applications
leurs données personnelles sont
transmises à des partenaires commerciaux
et notamment des partenaires américains
comme localytics et vous savez que c'est
illégal
[Rires]
on est bien l'équipe
ce concert se faire vacciner
le voilà qui déboule avec une nouvelle
technique de séduction
auj
[Musique]
mais là encore c'est bon je les prends
ça tout est bien emballé avec ses potes
sale blague je puis donc un regard c'est
une campagne choc signé greenpeace
outre-manche pour dénoncer l'exportation
des déchets plastiques par la grande
bretagne
lowell j imagine le tender ning street
inondé par les poubelles l'association
estime que les britanniques envoient
chaque jour une tonne 8 de déchets
plastiques à traiter dans d'autres pays
du monde et qu'il est grand temps pour
boris johnson d'agir une étude révèle
que ces emballages alimentaires nous
seraient nocifs pour notre santé des ong
européennes alerte sur la présence de
substances toxiques présentes dans les
sachets de frites les boîte de hamburger
ou encore des sacs à sandwich et à
pâtisserie de notre boulanger avec
joshua on est des grands romantiques
donc on a décidé de fêter ça dignement
castro est arrivé franchement c'est tout
aussi bien et ça nous ressemble
tellement au fait les images satellites
sont impressionnantes l'iceberg le plus
gros du monde s'est détaché de
l'antarctique
baptisé à 76 l'énorme bloc de glace fait
environ 170 km de long sur 25 km de
large pour une surface totale de 4
milles 320 kilomètres carrés équivalente
à la moitié de la corse
on est obligé d'accélérer 1 vous en
voulez pas mais sinon ça aurait été un
peu long pour safari une adresse mail
pour chrome une adresse mail pour
firefox
une adresse mail pour opera il n'adresse
mai